[Music]
and welcome back to Hannity so residents
of Redlands California are in Shock that
two of their neighbors carried out
yesterday's deadly mass shootings now
last night one area worker told the
local news station quote he noticed a
half dozen Middle Eastern men in the
area in recent weeks but decided not to
report anything since he didn't wish to
racially profile those people he went on
to say quote now we'd see them leave
when they were where they're raiding the
apartment so to political correctness
prevent the rocity from being stopped
and is it time to start spying on some
mosqu that we believe have radical ties
joining us now the author of the
complete infidels guide to Isis Jihad
watch director Robert Spencer and from
the amadia Muslim Community Harris Zafar
is with us all right if you go back
Robert and look at remember the kid with
the clock bomb remember the MRC did a
man on the street they showed the device
to 50 people all 50 people thought it
was a bomb the teacher reported it look
at all the trouble the teacher got in
then you have this case where people see
a lot of suspicious activity they don't
want to be accused of being of racially
profiling and they don't say a word are
we at a point that maybe this this act
could have been stopped if people would
have just spoken up but fear of
political correctness prevented him
there's no doubt about it Sean
absolutely and this goes back years the
Fort Dicks Jihad plot was in 2007 and
there was a young man who uncovered the
plot inadvertently and he also was
afraid to go to police initially for
fear of being called racist groups like
the Hamas link Council on American
Islamic relations and others have for
years tried to stigmatize any resistance
to Jihad Terror as racism and bigotry
and we see in this incident now with the
neighbor how successful they have been
and the whole moral of the story of that
clock hoax bomb that the young man
brought to school is if you see
something say something unless it's a
Muslim anybody who now who knows that uh
who realizes what happened in that case
is going to be afraid to go to
authorities they'll know it'll be career
suicide to do so you know we're now at
the point where PC Harris is silencing
people and it can have lethal
consequences now I know a lot of people
and I know your community by the way has
been outspoken against radical islamist
but even this President is too cowardly
to say the words radical islamist or
radical Jihad or radical Islamic Terror
there's a mysterious reluctance and
resistance that's almost pathological
now and I would even argue is putting
people in danger do you agree with
that well uh thanks for having me uh
within the amadia Muslim Community our
belief is that it it it does miss this
conversation misses the Nuance that it
deserves on the one hand uh we do
understand we do agree that terrorism
and violence and murder does violate exp
explicit teachings in the Quran but to
your point on the other hand it is
unfair to say that Islam or religion has
no role to play because groups like Di
do use Islam or religion to beautify an
otherwise ugly ideology in their
recruitment uh to show that it's a
greater than purpose as radical
islamists are at war with us there're at
war with Europeans there at war with the
Western world there's a clash of
cultures here and and this is something
I think America's got to come to grips
with if you grow up in a country under
Sharia law where let's take Saudi Arabia
where we we think they visited okay
women can't drive women have to dress a
certain way women can't go out and
public without a male relative in other
countes Sharia law women need four male
eyewitnesses to prove rape if you grow
up in that country how do we ascertain
if somebody is willing to assimilate
they want the breath of freedom and a
new life for themselves and their family
or if they want to bring their ideas
their culture with them because I don't
think you can read hearts and minds or
ascertain where people's hearts are do
you so the way that we with an Community
are are trying to path this uh path this
this forward uh uh ideology is by
defining what we call true Islam and
make Muslims explain do they agree with
the principles of true Islam that true
Islam does separation of religion Rel
Champion the the uh which is why we're
talking about let Muslims and
non-muslims tell us who agrees with the
definition of true Islam that it does
Champion the empowerment of women that
it calls for a separation of religion
and state have that
RL take the words out of the Quran the
Hadith and they use it to justify
killing take neither Christians nor Jews
for your friends uh Jihad Infidel all
those words they take it literally and
and as literal they look at the life of
Muhammad a warrior his life his
background and they feel that they ought
to replicate the caliphate
correct absolutely yes and it's that
lure of the caliphate that has drawn
30,000 Muslims from around the world to
go to Iraq and Syria to Jo the Islamic
State because they read the same Quran
including at least 250 Muslims from the
United States yeah what about and this
goes to the recogize this goes to the
heart of the 10,000 refugees that the
president wants to bring in from Syria
uh our intelligence director the
Director of National Intelligence James
Clapper our FBI director assistant FBI
director other intelligence sourcers
Robert they say that Isis will
infiltrate the refugee Community coming
from Syria why would the president of
the United States in light of Paris in
light of San Bernardino gamble with the
lives of the American
people it just seems as if he is
refusing to acknowledge this problem at
all the Islamic state has already
boasted about placing jihadis among the
refugees they have warned their people
they have instructed their people I
should say not to appear overtly Islamic
to appear moderate not to carry around
the Quran not to go to mosque just to
wait until they're called upon to commit
mass murder in the name of Islam and so
there is absolutely no way to vet among
these refugees and of course the Obama
Administration can't vet them anyway
because they won't even admit there is a
Jihad how are they going to determine
who the jihadis are among the refugees
it's absolutely absurd all right thank
you both for being with us we appreciate
your time